[Musica]
ma dico io a quest'ora della sera siete
ancora desiderosi e desiderosa no perché
i desideri hanno anche dei limiti
diciamocelo dopo tutta questa giornata
io per esempio un limite cielo fra i
tanti cioè quando mi chiedono se mi
piacciono i dolci io tendo a rispondere
subito no lascia perdere perché proprio
i dolci non li desidero ma non è proprio
così perché se mi offrite anche domani e
con calma una fetta di torta di ricotta
e pere io non resisto e o un moto di
commozione vera ma c'è un perché
perché una mattina ero appena entrata a
scuola e in aula ho sentito un leggero
tocco sulla spalla e quando mi sono
girata e ho visto una magnifica torta di
ricotta e pere appunto è subito dietro
lo sguardo brillante di una mia luna
dodicenne e la sua voce si era decisa
che mi dice prof l'assaggio questo era
un mio non so
era successo di giorno prima in quel
gruppo di preadolescenti che stavo
osservando da un po e mi sembravano
frenati già discreti
militanti della competizione
ma altrettanto schiacciati sulle
prestazioni sulle ansie sulle
aspettative degli adulti
io ho deciso di proporre una cosa ho
detto loro prendete un foglio
e scrivete dalle 5 alle 10 cose anzi in
realtà
siccome ero la prof di matematica
oggetto scrivete un numero compreso fra
5 e 10 di cose che siete davvero
convinti di non saper fare
quando avete finito
cancellate in un so all'inizio di ogni
frase è sostituita lì con posso o voglio
e poi prendetevi qualche istante per
rileggere le frasi così trasformate e
magari sentire che effetto vi fa
vedete io
avevo l'intenzione di attivare un
movimento verso qualcosa che intuivo che
quei ragazzi si stavano precludendo da
soli e non per sottoscrivere il vecchio
detto
volere è potere tanto meno per fare del
pensiero positivo
molto più semplicemente
volevo provare ad aprire un varco
proprio una fessura di fiducia
socchiudere una porta di blindata che io
sentivo li stava separando dalla vita e
soprattutto che aveva su di sé una targa
gigantesca e c'era scritto io non sono
capace
e comunque quella torta di ricotta e
pera quella metamorfosi dal non so a
posto vi assicuro era buonissimo tant'è
vero che non resisto neanche adesso
il fatto è che al momento della nostra
nascita
sicuramente qualcuno ha detto o ha
scritto di noi è venuta alla luce
e al momento della nostra morte qualcun
altro probabilmente dirà o scriverà si è
spenta ma non so voi a me interessa
quello che c'è nel mezzo e in mezzo
quando e come impariamo ad accendere la
luce e soprattutto a mantenerla accesa
prima però dobbiamo sfatare un luogo
comune
anche in questi tempi di pandemie luoghi
comuni sono rimasti drammaticamente
affollati il luogo comune per cui noi
saremmo capaci di desiderare tanto più
quando su quanto siamo nati dal
desiderio dei nostri genitori
allora diciamocela tutta con franchezza
a partire da me se così fosse la metà di
noi non sarebbe in grado di accendere la
linea del compleanno
invece
io sono convinta credo per fortuna il
desiderio si impara
se penso a me la rintraccio facilmente
la mia prima esperienza cosciente del
desiderare
aveva 89 anni e per il mio io di
quell'età una bicicletta era il
salvacondotto verso l'avventura el
indipendenza era letteralmente
lo svincolo a due ruote dall'infanzia
ma all'epoca i miei genitori ei miei
nonni mi posero una condizione ferma è
molto semplice la bici sarebbe arrivata
ma solo alla fine dell'anno scolastico e
solo se avessi guadagnato una delle
borse di studio che metteva a
disposizione lente per cui lavorava mio
padre
ebbene io tutti quei mesi e sono stati
davvero tanti me li ricordo ancora
tutti i giorni sono stata in compagnia
di due cose
dell'attesa e dell'immaginazione e
guardate che immaginare è molto diverso
da fantasticare
prima ho visto il colore rosso poi sono
arrivati particolari il manubrio cromato
il piccolo fanale il sellino il
portapacchi poi mi ci sono vista su e ho
sentito il suono delle ruote che
stridevano sull'asfalto e poi suono del
campanello e la pressione dei miei piedi
sui pedali
l'effetto dell'aria sulle guance ma
soprattutto
la gioia è il senso prorompente di
libertà
questo sentivo fervido e reale
e questa sono io
alla fine della mia prima scuola di
desiderio e dei suoi ingredienti non so
se si vede la mia faccia
ma ciò per quella faccia di una testata
promossa
e oggi
è vero che viviamo un tempo dannatamente
scomodo per tutti e per tutte ma voglio
dirlo chiaro che per le bambine per i
bambini questo è molto più scomodo come
tempo da vivere
e allora quanto
loro fanno l'esperienza non solo
dell'attesa e dell'immaginazione ma
anche di altri ingredienti che sono
fondamentali per imparare a desiderare
per esempio del silenzio quel silenzio
buono che parla il linguaggio del
dialogo ancestrale con tutti gli esseri
viventi e non viventi e poi della noia
che vi assicuro spaventa tantissimo
soprattutto i genitori è che è uno
spazio vuoto un tempo sospeso è
un'avventura della mente e l'ascolto del
niente che attira tutto anche della
confusione da cui però arrivano immagini
nuove
io temo che troppo spesso le bambine i
bambini invece sentono questo e imparano
questo che il silenzio è una cosa brutta
ostile e spaventosa che ha il sapore del
rimprovero e della riprovazione
e che la vita è uno spazio da riempire
di corsa
i desideri esattamente come gli oggetti
merci da acquistare da consumare con
voracità e magari per sentirsi migliori
e allora io davanti a queste cose provo
a farmi una domanda che per me è la più
corretta la pongo anche a voi allora
cosa posso fare io
cosa possiamo fare noi
a parte fare i conti con le nostre paure
io provo a portarvi in due parole che ho
raccolto da loro da bambini ed
adolescenti
per esempio quella volta che un
ragazzino di 11 anni
parlandomi delle notizie che portano
ogni giorno dal mondo storie di
ingiustizie violenze guerre malattie
atrocità quelle stesse che noi prima
guardiamo un po sgomenti poi turbati e
via via più anestetizzati lui mi ha
detto un giorno rosi io davanti a questo
mi sento
sconcertato
cioè privato del concerto non ci avevo
mai pensato prima che la parola concerto
è una parola meravigliosa perché
concerto significa attendere insieme
verso qualcosa quindi quel bambino mi
stava dicendo del suo desiderio di
cercare tutti insieme un'armonia comune
e poi c'è un'altra parola che ricorre
guardate quasi tutte le volte che
incontrò gli adolescenti non mi sento
considerato dai grandi
considerazione è la seconda parola che
vi porto
ed è sorprendente la sapienza delle
parole che usano i bambini perché
desiderio e considerazione contengono
entrambe le stelle e allora quando ci
dicono non mi sento considerato ci
stanno dicendo aiutaci a sentirci parte
della stessa costellazione di umani
questo ci stanno dicendo
quindi quello che possiamo dare loro e
provare a vederli e provare ad
ascoltarli
io una sintesi efficace
l'ho trovata su una scritta che è
comparsa qualche mese fa a roma sulla
scalinata della galleria d arte moderna
non so se la leggete
è la citazione di una straordinaria
filosofa maria zambrano e dice così dice
le radici devono avere fiducia nei fiori
allora quello che io mi propongo c
propongo è proprio di fare una scelta
radicale
riprenderci il compito di radici
perché le radici
non hanno paura del buio sono lì e si
aggrappano con forza alla terra non si
chiedono mai che cosa c'è su e tanto
meno se il fiore ce la farà
semplicemente lo spingono verso il cielo
questo fanno le radici e questo possiamo
fare noi
starete pensando questa la fa veramente
molto negativa perché effettivamente i
bambini e le bambine di oggi stanno
molto meglio di quali cent'anni cento
anni fa vero lo confermo
ed è anche vero che abbiamo imparato
piano piano almeno a nominare alcuni
bisogni dei bambini almeno sappiamo che
esistono no e sappiamo che i bisogni
sono una dimensione essenziale della
nostra esistenza
il bisogno però non ha un verbo
corrispondente a una piccola famiglia
per esempio a come parenti stretti
l'urgenza e la necessità il bisogno vive
improrogabilmente nel presente
il desiderio ce l'ha è come un verbo
significa che contiene già l'idea del
movimento e poi a me piace perché ha una
famiglia numerosa ha come fratelli il
coraggio e il tempo ea come sorelle
delle tipe molto interessanti
l'immaginazione che vi ho già presentato
la fiducia e soprattutto una piccola
essenziale la
e la sua casa la casa del desiderio e la
casa dei bambini e delle bambine e la
casa del loro diritto è il futuro
vero sarete ancora pensando
tante cose abbiamo
provato a farle stiamo provando a farle
per i bambini per esempio nel mondo che
io conosco meglio che è il mondo della
scuola da almeno 15 anni abbiamo
meritoriamente dato attenzione ad alcuni
bisogni di bambine e bambini e li
abbiamo anche raggruppati all'interno di
una grande sigla che è bes
i bisogni educativi speciali e
importantissimo che l'abbiamo fatto
tuttavia mi viene qualche dubbio perché
ho la sensazione che rischiamo di
confondere qualche volta i bisogni con
l'identità dei singoli bambini lo dico
perché spesso mi capita di ascoltare
come gli insegnanti raccontano sapete
che il modo in cui ci rappresentiamo
l'esperienza è particolarmente
interessante avrà ascolto gli insegnanti
che raccontano del loro hanno passato
per esempio così quest'anno è stato
veramente molto faticoso avevo una
classe con tre best e quattro di esse ha
invece che dire una classe con tre
bambini con bisogni educativi speciali e
quattro bambini con disturbi specifici
dell'apprendimento
e a questo proposito io credo sia
necessario che continuiamo ad
interrogarci
su come aiutare i bambini con bisogni
educativi speciali disturbi specifici
dell'apprendimento aiutarli a crescere e
dare loro le stesse opportunità di tutti
ma se nello stesso tempo
contemporaneamente cominciassimo a farci
delle domande
anche sui disturbi specifici
dell'insegnamento
e sui disturbi specifici dell'educazione
se cominciassimo provassimo almeno ad
allargare lo sguardo
daibes quindi da solo soggetti con i
bisogni aides ai desideri educativi
speciali
io sento che così avremo qualche
possibilità in più di intercettare
quelle domande che premono dietro gli
occhi dei bambini di ogni tempo
anche di questo perché i bambini e le
bambine sono esperti in interrogativi
cosmici sono le stesse domande che a un
certo punto della vita molti di noi
smettono di farsi e sono delle domande
che io stasera di consegna se volete le
mettete in tasca non mettete in borsa e
quando viva tiratele fuori non per
rispondere ma semplicemente per fargli
prendere aria perché mai come ora c'è
bisogno di queste domande le domande di
sempre dei bambini e chi sono è perché
sono qui
mi sento ancora molto vicina a loro
mentre si fanno queste domande e per
questo vi lascio con le parole che per
provare a rispondere ha usato eduardo
galeano che penso poco fa abbia citato
anche tonio eduardo galeano prova a
rispondere nella sua finestra sul volto
e il volto è quanto di più umano ci
resti
prova a dirci secondo lui
chi siamo e perché siamo qua e lo fa
così
una macchina stupida
una lettera che ignora il suo mittente
ha sbagliato destinazione o una
pallottola perduta che un dio ha sparato
per errore
noi veniamo da un nuovo più piccolo
della testa di un e viviamo su una
pietra che gira intorno ad una stella
nana e che contro questa stella prima o
poi si scontrerà
tuttavia siamo stati fatti di luce oltre
che di carbonio di ossigeno di merda e
di altre cose ma in fin dei conti siamo
qui da quando la bellezza dell'universo
ha avuto bisogno di essere vista da
qualcuno
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]